this is our third match today we first
etc' lost by one question and Weaver's
line the Wolves of Steel and we lost by
one question again question is but today
we're going to take on the Wenger's I'm
so excited because I'm in love with
Christian and he doesn't know this but
I've been wanting to make love with him
for a long time so I'm hoping that after
I win this match today that he will make
sweet sweet passionate love to both John
hi guys Greg here Andrew here Andrew
with the channel movie source channel
movie content movie movie movie movie so
this is not a movie this is a show
called Gotham they're introducing all of
like Batman's rogues gallery but way
before he's in what or is it show which
is very weird I don't show a follow
Gotham I don't I watched the first two
episodes and I lost interest quickly so
now then what I've heard it's pretty
cool though I've heard he gets better
and I should give it a chance there's
just a lot of TV shows out there to
watch it doesn't feel ring very true to
the Batman mythos but I mean you got a
respected we're trying to have its own
like interpretation but the biggest
criticism I have of the shows Batman's a
kid and you got all these rogues coming
in while he's a child but I mean there
are some interesting storylines for sure
and I do love Robin Taylor Thomas I
believe his name is the pain when he's
great as on both Cobblepot
there's his trailer Jerome reborn where
he's officially the Joker yeah and he
was kind of a joker and season two as
well the actor who plays with Cameron I
forgot his long hat Monaghan he's also
on shameless but is Jerome in the season
two I really thought I liked his laugh
like you just really gave up that Mark
Hamill kind of vibe so I'm really
curious to see how you know this version
is going to be - character kind of died
from Azrael I believe killed them in
season two so it's going to be
interesting to see what happens hear how
he gets resurrected alright enthusiasm
through the roof
[Music]
[Music]
your legacy will be death Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you promised them
[Music]
[Music]
see what you are till you want you to
healthy boy
Oh
[Music]
I don't want a lot this account not just
a call anymore ordinary citizens are
second to rob loose when I have some fun
before the main event now I say
investors in the charcoal Brown play
down
Oh someone back in on with it so him and
I with a bang
or better yet of all ready nominally ACK
- man no hero
[Music]
oh man
we're looking at the birth of Batman
there Hey look that makes that that
immediately makes me go I should
probably catch up so I can start
watching this show that looks [ __ ]
awesome
yeah no it did look really cool too and
I do like I said I really like this guy
as Joker and I'm gonna give maybe a
little bit of an unpopular opinion but I
like a little more than Jared Leto's
version so far the Joker getting back to
this I will say that his his face has a
restage it can remind me a little bit of
jigsaw from The Punisher a little bit of
it well yeah I mean from the minor
information that we know about the new
52 that's what he does yeah yeah someone
takes his face me staples it back on oh
yeah I'm gonna give me that little face
off vibe of Nicolas Cage and John
Travolta in their faces or a twitch and
stuff it seems like a really good
direction for the show yeah because I
haven't been following the show but this
immediately hooked me because it's weird
that we're getting a whole like Joker
origin tale prior to him becoming Batman
but I like how they're doing their own
version yeah where it's influencing
Bruce Wayne you obviously these events
are going to haunt Bruce Wayne if you
actually make it even more of a personal
villain for Privett man like you're
actually amplifying the reason they
become archenemies for the rest of their
lives yeah also you're building in that
fact history to like also they're going
to have many more years of fighting not
just when he was Batman in jokes also
now it's starting with Bruce Wayne
obviously Joker when you fight some
years later it's Batman he's not going
to know he's Bruce Wayne but from
Bruce's point of view it's going to be
interesting he hasn't just been haunted
by this guy Danny years of Batman also
it's Bruce Wayne and - I got a little
bit of a vibe from in that when they're
in that glass room and they're kind of
fighting each other kind of give me a
little bit of the interrogation scene
from Dark Knight a little bit it's just
mano a mano and like they're in a glass
room kinda so I mean that was pretty
cool to see Batman him putting blood on
his face with the Joker makeup like I've
never even ever seen like the Joker
doing something like that to Batman even
though he's not Batman yet he's still
Bruce Wayne but still just to see him do
that to the person who will become
Batman one day it was just very
interesting and different and it's
different so that's cool that they're
you know
respect for them going with their own
version of it like I thought I wasn't
really welcome by the trailer because
going just from Jerome for like most of
this trailer and seeing what's going on
with the Joker what's so fascinating
that I was like it's just going to be
the show now are we even going to get
back to like Jim Gordon and everything
so I finally went back to them it made
me feel like this is a storyline for a
full season that I could get on board
with this is something that has hooked
me that's making me go I want to see
these events actually play out and I
like out that there's retelling going on
while still taking influences from other
source material of course this has a
whole new dimension for like the Batman
mythology in a way yeah definitely and
like I said I like them doing like their
own version and like I said like them
starting off the pack is the backstory
my treating that history for them from
when Bruce was a kid like like you said
he's going to be haunted from this
character now from when he was a kid
rather and when he's you know the cloud
characters Batman so it's really
interesting and cool to see from that
perspective and also to you got that one
guy he's in the dirt in it alright not
yeah so that's pretty cool I worked for
the Joker in the night and the
schizophrenic I think writing to food
yes Thomas Thomas yeah guy was just the
shoot Jim Gordon yeah it's funny to have
him in this electric kind of ship also -
I think he was in could be running as an
ant-man you see the the guy the computer
guy I compute that or that guy yeah so
this show seems to be going down a route
now where it's less based on these other
characters and they're like let's
capitalize off of Bruce Wayne now and
let's capitalize off Joker we can you
can use these guys here so this is cool
if I could see this leading into like
Bruce Wayne becoming Batman eventually
into this [ __ ] which would be so [ __ ]
on yeah have a TV adaptation of Batman
that that seems like it could work if
they build it right know for sure and I
mean just seeing this like I'm already
foreshadowing and thinking in the future
as you just mentioned one already and be
Batman and diesel yeah this version of
Batman and this version of Joker like
space on a beef identical but after we
see like again the backstory in the
history that's going to start here maybe
in a few seasons we get hopefully that
wish and then like we'll have this to
build up on from an L oh there's like
there's that history no there's that
that they had that chemistry from from
starting up where we saw them a couple
seasons ago this battle has been really
brewing in the making for years to come
it'll be a little more melee a lot of
impact I can see a strong defining path
or whether show is aiming to get
I can see where the shows really aiming
to end up yeah alright sweetie thanks
for telling me I voyages I don't watch a
show I think I'm gonna start the show I
think I got to finish the show nap and I
know you watch the show so hell yeah
alright guys subscribe to the real
rejects thanks for recommending that my
way subscribe to and you're on the movie
source channel retox more movies and
[ __ ] like that and Lego Batman movie I
might do a review for it or it might be
watching 50 shades darker what do you
guys want me to watch fifty shades
darker visit us at facebook.com slash
the real rejects request to put down
your request today